[Música]
todos tenemos un amigo ecologista por
allí ustedes todavía no lo identificaron
pero está por allí se los aseguro es ese
que se queja de los vasos descartables
el que los va siguiendo en la casa
pagando cada luz que encendieron o el
que en la oficina les envío un email que
dice no ven primas y presten de que
memorice mos las 500 cosas que escribió
me causaba gracia me parecía exagerado
pero a la larga le di la razón creo que
todos le dimos la razón lo cierto es que
la manera en que vivimos lo que hacemos
lo que consumimos va dejando una huella
de emisiones a nuestro paso para un
argentino promedio el tamaño de esa
huella ronda las 6 toneladas de dióxido
de carbono al año pero de dónde salen
estas emisiones acompáñenme visualizando
una chimenea de la que sale humo todo el
tiempo las 24 horas los 365 días del año
es la chimenea de una planta
termoeléctrica cada vez que encendemos
la luz el televisor o cargamos el
celular en argentina
qué estás quemando un combustible fósil
que genera la electricidad que hace que
todo eso funcione
productos que adquirimos también tienen
una huella de carbono
para fabricar esta camisa se generaron
emisiones en los cultivos de algodón en
la industria textil y en el transporte
que lo llevó hasta el comercio que lo
quería todas esas emisiones hacen la
huella de carbono de esta camisa y yo
como su comprador soy el responsable
indirecto de que hayan ocurrido
si hubiéramos en suecia podríamos
contabilizar estas emisiones
allí ya existe la primera tarjeta de
crédito que limita el impacto climático
de nuestros consumos los que la tienen
van sumando con cada compra sus
emisiones asociadas compra de un pasaje
aéreo sumó 300 kilogramos por las
emisiones de la quema de combustible
compra de hamburguesas sumó 50
kilogramos por las emisiones de las
vacas compra de resmas de papel sumó 100
kilogramos por las emisiones de la tala
de árboles y así van sumando emisiones
hasta que llegan un límite y la tarjeta
se bloquea
está bueno preguntarse que estaríamos
nosotros dispuestos a dejar de consumir
para no pasar ese límite
cuando me recibí de biólogo mi amigo
ecologista ya llevaba años taladrando me
la cabeza con esto de reducir la huella
de hecho ya había cambiado muchos de mis
hábitos pero aún no estaba satisfecho
los impactos del cambio climático eran
cada vez más visibles y yo quería estar
allí donde se estaban tomando las
decisiones para hacerle frente fue así
cómo empecé mi carrera en la secretaría
de ambiente los 7 años que fui director
de cambio climático me sirvieron para
confirmar el rol clave que los gobiernos
juegan en primer lugar en las medidas
para prepararnos y adaptarnos frente al
cambio en el clima y en segundo
estableciendo los incentivos necesarios
para que la reducción de emisiones
ocurra incentivos como los programas de
etiquetado ambiental que nos ayudan a
comprar de una manera más sustentable o
las acciones que promueven la el uso de
la bicicleta o del transporte público en
detrimento del uso del auto
en otra escala los países también tienen
una huella de carbono que depende de la
actividad principal de su economía de la
energía que utilizan y del estilo de
vida de sus habitantes los países que
tienen una economía basada en el campo o
en la industria pesada en general tienen
huellas de carbono mayores que aquellos
países que basan su economía en los
servicios los países que generan su
electricidad exclusivamente de la quema
de combustibles fósiles suelen tener
mayores emisiones que aquellos que lo
hacen incorporando también las energías
renovables energías como la eólica o la
solar que permiten que cada vez que
encendemos la luz haya menos chimeneas
emitiendo
las medidas para combatir el
calentamiento del planeta afectan los
intereses de otros países por lo que es
necesario negociar acuerdos los acuerdos
climáticos surgen por primera vez en la
cumbre de la tierra de 1992 en respuesta
a las alertas de un panel global de
científicos este panel conocido como el
ipcc ganaría después el premio nobel por
sus aportes al conocimiento de las
emisiones y sus efectos sobre el
calentamiento del planeta
todos los años los países se reúnen en
negociar estos acuerdos en el marco de
cumbres del clima yo recuerdo muy bien
la primera vez que participé en una de
estas cumbres en bali indonesia habían
llegado representantes de más de 100
países presidentes
cancilleres ministros de ambiente
diplomáticos todos juntos en los salones
de un hotel que era imponente en los
alrededores había miles de activistas
que llevan adelante manifestaciones con
el objeto de meter presión a los
negociadores para que los acuerdos
avanzarán más rápidamente yo había
recibido instrucciones muy claras de mi
gobierno proteger nuestros intereses
comerciales eso en la negociación
significaba no aceptar límites a nuestra
capacidad de explotar recursos naturales
como el petróleo y los bosques
por el contrario yo creía firmemente que
en argentina había que hacer algo para
detener los desmontes de repente me
encontré dudando si realmente estaba
jugando en el equipo correcto los
intereses de mi país al menos en ese
punto claramente no iban en línea con
los intereses del planeta incluso me
cuestioné si no debía atravesar la
barrera de seguridad que me separaba de
los activistas climáticos y unirme a sus
protestas a su reclamo por metas más
ambiciosas
estos intereses contrapuestos que son
comunes a muchos negociadores son una de
las razones por las que estas cumbres
producen resultados tan pobres
si me fueran un poco las reuniones en
estas cumbres no se diferencian
demasiado en las reuniones de mi
consorcio donde llevamos años
discutiendo qué hacer con la caldera el
tema es que funciona mal entonces en el
invierno del edificio se sobrecalienta
este año el administrador nos convocó y
nos propuso dos medidas la primera
atacar las causas de la problemática es
decir el mal funcionamiento de la
caldera mientras tanto como el arreglo
iba a tardar nos propuso una medida de
adaptación frente al calor todos
debíamos dejar abiertas las ventanas del
edificio para que se enfriara después
viene la parte más salada quien se hace
cargo de los costos de la reparación
todos presentamos nuestras posiciones
negociamos y finalmente llegamos a un
acuerdo los que tenían departamentos de
superficie mayor cubriría en una mayor
parte de los costos por otro lado en la
negociación internacional los países
nunca se han puesto de acuerdo sobre
cómo distribuir los costos para arreglar
el cambio climático algunos piensan que
los países como eeuu que son
responsables de las mayores emisiones
históricas deberían cubrir la mayor
parte otros en cambio creen que el
criterio utilizar debería ser el nivel
de emisiones hoy que ubica a países como
china en los primeros lugares y así
entre la búsqueda de financiadores y
responsables estamos hace años y
mientras tanto la caldera sigue sobre
calentando
los acuerdos climáticos van
evolucionando a lo largo del tiempo en
el protocolo de kioto de 1997 las metas
de reducción de emisiones eran solo para
los países desarrollados más
recientemente en el acuerdo de parís de
2015 las metas se extienden a todos los
países que en conjunto se proponen
mantener el incremento de la temperatura
por debajo de los dos grados
vale aclarar que la tierra se viene
calentando desde el inicio de la
revolución industrial y que al presente
la temperatura ya se incrementó en un
grado piensen en todo lo que eso ya
significó los huracanes que han
devastado islas completas en el caribe
las olas de calor en la unión europea
las inundaciones y las sequías que hemos
tenido aquí en argentina ahora imaginen
eso con un grado más
el acuerdo de parís fue firmado por 200
países pero entre ellos solamente 15
encabezados por china y eeuu concentran
el 70% de las emisiones del planeta el
acuerdo también incluye a islas como
tuvalú que tienen el 00000 1% de las
emisiones es decir nada que motiva a una
isla como tuvalú y otros tantos países
con emisiones ínfimas a participar de
estos acuerdos
mi experiencia en la negociación me
llevó a concluir que estos acuerdos no
son sólo climáticos
para algunos son también acuerdos
comerciales para otros de desarrollo y
para otros incluso son acuerdos
humanitarios detrás de cada párrafo se
esconden intereses nacionales que en
general priman por sobre los intereses
globales intereses económicos como los
que tienen los países petroleros que ven
estos acuerdos como una barrera a los
combustibles que producen intereses de
sobrevivencia como los que tienen tuvalú
y otras islas que ven estos acuerdos
como la salvación la posibilidad de
detener el incremento del nivel del mar
que pone en riesgo su completa
existencia
detrás estos intereses también se
esconden las razones por las que eeuu ha
anunciado que abandonara el acuerdo de
parís ellos lo ven como una amenaza a su
persistencia como primera potencia
mundial consideran que las metas de
reducción de emisiones en su territorio
incrementarán sus costos de producción y
que eso los hará perder competitividad
frente a otros países como china que
tendrían metas menos exigentes
en la negociación también se juegan
cuestiones éticas vinculadas con la
equidad
un ciudadano promedio en eeuu consume 5
veces más productos y servicios que uno
en china
mejorar el nivel de vida de los chinos
al menos lograr que todos accedan a una
heladera y al mínimo de oro
indefectiblemente incrementará las
emisiones de este país
no me malinterpreten no estoy diciendo
que china deba seguir el mismo camino de
desarrollo que siguieron países como
eeuu porque eso fue lo que nos llevó al
problema
hoy tenemos conocimiento y tecnología
que permiten que los países se
desarrollen de una manera más
sustentable pero no se equivoquen con
eso solo no alcanza además hay que
reducir el consumo hay que de
materializar la economía dicho en
términos criollos para el ambiente un
sorbete de cartón es mejor que un
sorbete de plástico pero mucho mejor es
si podemos prescindir de ellos
para finalizar quisiera volver a ese
amigo ecologista ese loco lindo que
todos tenemos y que muchas veces
ignoramos ese que algunos llaman
conciencia ambiental
bueno el planeta necesita que le
prestemos más atención necesita que
nuestros eventos limitemos el uso de
descartables que nuestras oficinas
imprimamos solo necesario que nuestras
casas
ahorremos energía que para movernos
usemos lo menos posible el auto los
avances en la implementación del acuerdo
de parís son lentos es como la
negociación del consorcio del infierno
todos están quemando pero en lugar de
preocuparse por apagar el incendio cada
uno está intentando salvar lo que puede
de su propio departamento por eso
necesitamos otro tipo de acuerdo uno que
incluya a todos los ciudadanos que están
dispuestos a vivir una manera más
sustentable uno en el que no importen
las nacionalidades porque lo que se
defiende es el lugar común
a lo largo de todo el planeta y hay
millones de ciudadanos que se están
organizando que sin importar la posición
del gobierno de su país están empezando
a cambiar sus estilos de vida esos
ciudadanos globales entre los que espero
estén todos ustedes
ya comprendimos ya nos dimos cuenta que
si de verdad queremos que el clima no
cambie tenemos que empezar por cambiar
nosotros gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]